five hello and welcome everybody to the
h3 podcast live here with the very funny
incredible beautiful comedian Chris
D'Elia back on the show
today's sponsors are audible stamps calm
kaptara thank you to them you can catch
Chris on Netflix on comedians of the
world what another a grit was a 30
minutes right yeah yeah terrific 30
minutes set and if you want to catch
this beautiful man on tour go to Chris
D'Elia calm / tour now before we get
into anything Chris and yes I welcome
you back and thank you for being thank
you for having me back and there's
something that I think is urgent that I
need to show you so this is a trailer
from 2003 for a movie called tiptoes
okay all right and it's like I'm already
in yeah well and so it's starring
Matthew McConaughey Gary Oldman Peter
Dinklage Kate Beckinsale this is a
powerhouse yeah our power but back then
they were big - right yeah for sure
Peter Dinklage because that was before
giving bronze right he was not big that
no but he's not big now either is it
he's not big now in certain ways but in
other ways he's huge
all right cool so here we go this is
yeah right there
now I don't know if you're ready for
what you're about to see and I was in
the first time pretty much game for
anything Matthew McConaughey's in you be
a judge she's real and Stevens life
together was perfect
I've got to get going all right a second
[Music]
there's one small it can tear them apart
I think you're gonna let me know that
everyone in your pansies a [ __ ] this
is real duck gary oldman yes Bruno his
mom Kathleen and over behind the bars
students brothers off you could have
prepared us for this dog you think if
you embarrass me I'll never speak to you
again so just get it together when the
going gets rough it's only the size of
your heart
no you knocked up this great girl and
you didn't tell her that her baby's
probably gotta be live I'm not like you
we're all so cute and cuddly don't
discriminate against us
I can do what he wants to do
I'm ready for the dot relations what is
this man doing a new buddy
how does very open do that gay all the
way the door I'll put you down the aisle
fast Aaron's a very lucky guy just not
enough time to screw it up is just a
beginning
they'll be wrapped package is no doubt
about it can a loose and Langley
productions proudly present command
performances from Cape Anne man
performing a fuel economy Patricia
Arquette and in the role of a lifetime
the role of a lifetime
Wow
ethos because then because the door whoa
that's a real move yeah I never that's
that's I mean Wow how times have changed
yeah I mean I know I mean that really
puts it in place doesn't it but how does
Gary Oldman always place parts where
it's like he was in a movie once and I
mean I'm I know who he is I watched him
in a lot of things he was in a movie
once where I watched the whole movie and
like 4/5 in I was like is that Gary
Oldman like how does he the transformer
yeah what did they do but they didn't
have like CGI back then how did they
make him look all short I must must do
the walk around honestly she was
shooting them it was his breakout role
it was a his role of a lifetime yeah it
was he'll never when he was on when he
was shooting that he was like I'll never
Eclipse this that's it's called yeah
that's it it almost feels like a trailer
you know in a Tropic Thunder yes it
feels like a fake trailer yeah yes
darling Gary Oldman it has a dwarf wait
wait how did you fight people send this
[ __ ] to you I thought I just thought it
was on the Internet but how do so did
this movie there's no way it really
actually came out right no it came out
its reviews Connie it was big back you
can watch this online this movie exists
these are star power this is a high
budget film they were doing something
really socially conscious they did I
just looked it up it it screened at
Sundance in 2004 and got pan so hard
that they they just went straight to DVD
come out and but it I think the
intention was to come out and feed oh
yeah and a cast include Chad said
because he's very you know he's a dwarf
yeah he said that originally it was
meant to be something very socially yeah
conscious but in the Edit it turned out
to be some corny wrong like rom-com and
they were Hugh he was shocked by how the
but uh that's so see that's the thing
about being an actor I like doing
stand-up you're in control of it when
you're an actor you're like okay the
scripts good and then you shoot it but
then the directors are you don't really
know what they're doing
hmm and then they edit it you don't know
what they're doing and then the
producers who got their cut you don't
know what they're doing but the time
you're like oh I was in a horror movie
right yeah I always wonder how do you
pick a good movie like you just guess I
mean if you're at my level you just kind
of gasp but I mean if your method
conahey hopefully you're like you have
the pick of the litter you know yeah I
don't but like wow yeah I was wonder
about that like like how did how the
[ __ ] did Keanu Reeves like know that
like you don't know the matrix is gonna
be the matrix I mean let's be frank
about Keanu Reeves not the best act he's
my favorite he's my favorite movie I
just I feel like he must have got lucky
in the matrix right I don't know because
no but he's good because that's who he
is I'm not that guy but here's the thing
about he goes that's his big life yeah
whoa but here I think about counter
Eve's oh there's so few movie stars it's
like him Denzel Will Smith those like
the last like there's no like new ones
you know what I mean like even the guys
who are really good like Jake Gyllenhaal
and like Ryan who's that other one
Gosling yeah like they're not like
they're like actors do you know what I
mean right
Denzel when you go to Denzel movie when
you go to Al Pacino movie you know what
they're gonna be doing almost you know
Keanu you for sure you know you know so
you go to see because it's Keano
it's almost a genre you know yeah yeah
that's why I love him I love Denzel
and-and-and John wick is a Keano genre
it's fun it's basically the matrix part
yeah you know the trilogy part of the
same trilogy oh yeah so basically what
you're trying to say is that tiptoes is
probably oh I'm gonna watch it
yeah I love they should have just called
it we're all short I thought we have
been less little you know it's funny at
the time if they would have caught a
little people that probably would have
felt offensive but that's what you know
buddy now is now yeah
little people oh my even they even had a
line just because they're little people
doesn't mean they don't have big hearts
something like that honestly they should
have just called the movie we made this
movie yeah yeah yeah we did this format
don't forget this yeah
you know I think around the time
Leonardo DiCaprio did What's Eating
Gilbert Grape where he had his breakout
as a yeah I want to say [ __ ] but I
don't really know what how yeah I don't
know either I'm not sure how to say it
not to offend people well I don't I
never saw the movie so I don't even know
what is mmm with the mentally mentally
deficient what is the way to say that
without offending like really I don't
know what's the politically correct way
there's an intellectual disability
I don't okay so I can't keep up so
Leonardo DiCaprio plays somebody with an
intellectual disability that's a lot to
say there's a lot but at any rate I feel
like Oldman felt like he was doing that
for the war because I think they came
around the same time but also even if
they made that movie now you would have
to get real little pigs Apple couldn't
carry open as good as he is
exactly well you know what that's like
batch to any given day if it's a slow
slow news day like you guys like may
have uncovered this today this may bury
them and you're right yeah I'd be like
well they did this please never forget I
know this is this was 13 13 1990 16
years ago three nation a better [ __ ]
no no so you may you may have women we
may have when that being credited sure
let's just make a call right now to to
Matthew McConaughey Gary Oldman to who's
there yeah Kate Beckinsale that game
over what did they say
party's over Oh party I like party's
over let's have a nice day party
/ party's over you already here honey I
don't know what's better though that are
those commercials that Matthew
McConaughey are you kidding
yes I'm trying to find we didn't we do
the last time we were like what [ __ ]
with god Brooke yes
you know what well okay we could play
that the way that made it to one of our
we did a an episode at the end of the
year of our favor oh it's all that dude
his Lincoln commercials are so insane
okay so glad you aren't hey when he
first I don't know how old you guys are
but when he first came out in like a
time to kill that was like his break out
thing and he killed it he was like this
you it was a time to kill yes it was
yeah we thought everyone thought was
gonna be next Paul Newman he handsome
his [ __ ] a good actor and then he
started me and then so he be busy big
star and then he made these corny movies
kind of fell off then kind of climbed
his way back up was in the one the other
year Dallas buyers club won the Academy
Award and then was like alright [ __ ] it
and then just did these and was like I'm
back to being Matthew McConaughey yeah
it's like you it was like the almost
like John Travolta is the same way it
was like he can get back on top but then
he's not gonna he's like [ __ ] like with
Pulp Fiction he's like you know I mean
after pulp fiction yeah like I heard
that Quentin Tarantino had to like
convince him to do get shorty and
couldn't turn dinner didn't do get
shorty but he was like you got to do
this it's a good movie and gentle it's
like really I'd rather do some [ __ ]
[ __ ] either do but I don't know what
it is but you know it's a beautiful
thing they they straddle that line
between yeah great yeah yeah yeah and
total ass yeah I think though that goes
to like you got to take a shot you got
to take a shot you got to take a chance
cuz if you take a chance you can win big
but you know Vail [ __ ] huge I want to
pull up these Lincoln commercials now so
yeah the topic there's one I couldn't
find that's on there's so many of them
there are but there's in a few yeah I'm
gonna pull up the what the best ones I
could find well there's one that's on TV
right now or stuff oh yeah
I don't know yeah he gets in his Lincoln
he drives around there it's there's no
dialogue and then at the end he goes no
it doesn't it's not even a word he just
goes and there's a voice over there or
what no no that's my favorite one out he
goes wow they're [ __ ] they're taking
the piss out of the man
no I don't think so he's like hitting
the corners and then it shows him like
playing pool
at the same time but there's no dialogue
no voiceover and then at the end he goes
yeah I swear to Allah see that one god I
would ride so hard to fight and maybe
you guys back could find out well I am
but yeah what the one where he just goes
Dan because and YouTube man so this was
the I hadn't seen this one before but
this one's go wait no I think I've seen
this one yeah this one is where that
hard facing the bull quite epic no your
that is the premise
look at this [ __ ] guy he's acting
he's trying so hard yeah
I think the thing is if this move you
know it's like do you have to like it's
one of two things
he knows he's [ __ ] with us okay you
know take it if you maybe he knows maybe
he doesn't but if he doesn't then he's
buying all the [ __ ] that people are
feeding him over then go it's like yo
Matthew McConaughey you're the only guy
who can sit in this [ __ ] car oh yeah
yeah Johnny Depp
Matthew McConaughey might be a secret
Scientologist mmm I don't know the vibe
I get when yeah but this move when you
could sit like this move here yeah
that's a real actor good I gotta do that
right next like if I get a movie saying
I've never done that in real life but it
looks good as hell right hmm like you
got to be a real that's a big quote try
to pull that off you know it feels weird
to do the luring that's a big bull I
love it wow I wonder who wrote the
dialogue for this you know let's enjoy
this I'm not gonna be Gary Oldman and
that's the area open by the way Gary
Oldman as the dwarf
you wrote the dialyzer bull
let's enjoy this cinematic nice big ball
that's a big bowl
I guess all sorry Oh he knows the name
1,800 pounds and do whatever that woman
what are you doing with your fingers you
create vacuous thing this would be like
a dream you have yeah like a [ __ ]
terrifying dream that you have to
explain to a therapist thank you sir
thank you Sarah would that make me want
to buy a car and I'm gonna say straight
up that commercials [ __ ] stupid it's
a [ __ ] stupid commercial I will never
buy a Lincoln I wasn't gonna but guess
what you do wait the over man yeah
that's a [ __ ] stupidest commercial I
just don't understand like the budget
the writing the planning the execution
the hiring of Matthew McConaughey goes
in millions of dollars in effort and
time and manpower goes into this uh well
hey we're talking about it but but but
nobody's listening spying that Lincoln
yeah nobody also who what's a [ __ ]
Lincoln to begin with that's kind of
what was funny about the Matthew
McConaughey thing trying to act like I
guarantee you Matthew McConaughey a man
as rich as that does not drive a [ __ ]
link you know yeah I'm saying you know
what they did they definitely were like
they gave him one soon as I say you
could say you're driving or probably
gave it's in his [ __ ] ya garage I
yeah that that does kind of ruin like
like in the neck in the next movie where
you'd be like oh he's playing the guy in
the Lincoln commercials mm-hmm
she'd make a full movie of the Lincoln
commercial now now yeah yeah yeah now
I'm buying a [ __ ] Lincoln you know
how she kill did you notice that like
Shaquille Rosen he's in [ __ ] movie
trailers he's good like trying to be
badass that's a very good point Gila and
Shaq's a goofy [ __ ]
in every commercial chakras I'll air
shocks got the thing in his head where
exact can't believe I'm in this
commercial do not I mean and you're
watching it and you're like yeah we're
like this cream we're selling this cream
you rub on his leg you don't need to
tell me just I'll do it yeah you know
well the end this is so bad that's a
very good distinction but the only way
it would be okay I think for me is if
Matthew McConaughey was like new and he
was like did interviews like on like
late-night couches and he was like do
you see those [ __ ] Lincoln
commercials you know what I mean oh yeah
I'm taking their money then I'm in right
yeah that's not the case now in fact
he's been doing these commercials for
what I can only say decades yeah I mean
really these Lincoln commercials I'll
tell you they be go off for a living
this time no thanks Dallas buyers club I
think I think just Dallas I want to
associated with AIDS no no but I think
that I think that he did those movies
and he was like so hot and then the next
thing I was like what the [ __ ] is
Lincoln commercials that year it was
like in three just by the way I mean
he's a phenomenal I oh yeah great yeah I
mean lot have you seen true detective
she didn't want oh yeah it's all awesome
you yeah I mean I don't know I mean he
kind of plays that guy yeah so let's see
watch some other ones okay I think then
one here about this one and then I'm
gonna hopefully find the one that I was
talking about
you just need the living room within the
car sleep he's in the car with like
anything on the side that's a big family
wouldn't he be great for cut to him
doing a suicide in the garage and the
way kid because he looks on the suicidal
doesn't even sad well there's definitely
like yeah why are we not pretending like
he's the weird guy at the party hid like
[ __ ] he's playing pull himself we're
gonna hang out with the family like was
he doing and he was like talking here's
like saddest chair further away from
everybody I'm was like taking chords as
a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah why don't they do
it link in the car for [ __ ] are you
alright yeah if I'm at that dinner I'm
like amen are you are you alright - does
this would this would be after we had
the conversation you'd be like you know
what he says like me this is gonna cut
to him just breathing fumes that's
Lincoln right what happens is dicks out
look weird guy at the party that got in
trouble everyone doesn't like this guy
the lighting is real weird to look
slightly car commercials are always so
who's also who sang them look how close
up here's of the wheel like this that's
there that wasn't it I mean that was the
line but not the commercial but this was
the line actually about you [ __ ] off
look you gotta learn this video they cut
out the part where somebody yelled at
him about how he like grabbed some
lady's ass yeah really here but this is
the line actually he goes here
[Music]
I left forever
[Music]
no he said I have no good play well he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about staying the
actual line huh he's like I'm gonna do
it one two the director is that I'm
doing time and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna clarify what it sounds like
I've heard this 20 times and I've just
no no he does Wow that was like the end
of the sixth sense
I don't I don't like that commercial no
why is it the car commercials in general
are such ass uh what the [ __ ] just tell
me about the car I don't I don't know
let me most well no hold on let's just
say most commercials are just [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] and there's honestly no
excuse for that it's 30 [ __ ] seconds
make it good there should be zero bad
commercials hmm maybe 1% of commercials
should be bad it's so [ __ ] easy they
try so hard to get all these writers you
have to check with [ __ ] it Lincoln
it's okay although we do that it's so
[ __ ] terror it's so bad you just get
one guy be like this is a I'll talk
about this on my podcast like if you're
gonna if you have a commercial for pants
or whatever the [ __ ] it is just have a
guy coming to me like a these are the
[ __ ] these are the pants these pants are
great yeah go buy these pants if you
want these pants if you don't want these
pants then don't buy these pants well
you're not gonna be the guy with these
pants if I was in a commercial for pants
and I did that it would be good yeah if
you get somebody it don't have to be me
if you get him to do it well he might
[ __ ] no no he'll [ __ ] yeah
and you're like why is he the Lincoln
you still get a Lincoln there's no
[ __ ] reason
stand by this I'm gonna run for mayor on
this platform there's no reason I have
bad commercials well for about
commercial my favorite bad commercials
that stand out to me are Mentos you
probably recall yeah because it's it's
unforgettable how you probably haven't
seen these yeah let me show you in fact
yeah because they are so bad that
they're unforgettable and at least in
their case you know they're doing it on
purpose right that's them that's what
makes it forgivable I think though so
but we say Mentos this is [ __ ] say
Mentos wait Mentos commercial yeah wait
they say men toss yeah there was a
Mentos the freshmaker or whatever the
[ __ ] they say is it not American it's
not it might not be though technically
but this is
I love this I lost my virginity is
[Music]
whatup [ __ ] look at that would not
work at all wow you were right very very
very no hold on let me find another how
about that Greg walks into the interview
you'd be like what the [ __ ] dude are you
insane
yeah
the song is incredible I can't forget it
gets hit by a car what a day this goes
back what am I gonna do this is like
MacGyver basically
[Music]
go behind the car so much faster either
go behind the car min George mentos it's
so much faster walk behind the car men
to us dude must be not America he should
have [ __ ] got in the car strangled the
guy killed him and then gotten back at
right mentos for life I would eat what's
up let's he'd put some Mentos on his
corpse
what really good idea actually got the
car and it was Matthew McConaughey oh
man people need that higher I think
people need to hire you he's just like
those are some big balls Dan said he was
right what's real aright about one then
it's not American yeah makes mentos Dan
it's me it's too that's too far even for
the Italian goes into the car the guy is
on his phone and out of the car that
makes so much my whole life makes so
much no it [ __ ] pinstripe suit that's
so Italian what's so wait so please tell
me that Americans didn't make the link
in commercial then showed up on set the
Mentos commercial and they were like but
what that was literally them it was like
an inception inception thing about
commercial than a commercial and [ __ ]
they were like but why does he not have
a pinstripe suit and they're like well
they don't wear them in America he says
he needs to have a pinstripe suit like
let's change the whole commercial roll
around and then they were like yeah he
has a pinstripe suit wow dude Mentos
what's with the Italians they their
roots go deep in a lot of Industry they
make great cars great clothing and now
it turns out with their food or is a
fantastic yeah but now I found out there
making Mentos right why do you why are
Jews being accused of conspiracies when
really the Italians control everything
the Pope yeah also pet they have a
monopoly on pedophilia
as well they they get the corner market
area I mean I don't want that one but
I'm saying they've done they do they
love it yeah they're great at okay
they're they they look good while doing
it that's a bad commercial there was a
bad there's no excuse for it now it's so
true yeah and you know the Super Bowl is
such a scheme to because they do it just
for the commercials it's like [ __ ] you
is the British trick I'm not why I
didn't watch this it's the greatest
trick anybody let me tell you something
to anybody who says oh I watch this
Super Bowl just for the commercials is
the most boring person in the room okay
okay don't first of all first of all
those commercials [ __ ] suck right
they're not good okay right maybe they
used to be or something I don't know but
they're not now you watch them and this
I watch them like this
hey okay you watch the Super Bowl for
the Super Bowl okay right I don't watch
the Super Bowl okay what about the
halftime show I mean it just yeah it was
fine I mean you know I don't feel good
or bad I don't know how does even know
anyone eight people like love to make
fun of the halftime show
unless it's Beyonce you know what it
means because it's like Beyonce can't do
no wrong but like you knew being maroon
5 that there was gonna be like oh
they're gonna they're gonna make fun of
them you know but what shocked me about
getting Adam Levine is like of all the
artists that are popular like who gives
a [ __ ] about Adam Levine you know like
nobody really he's not like on the rise
I get it but he's so big though he has a
lot of hit when I heard you know I mean
he's got he's on that show right he's so
big they're so big and they have some
they have some [ __ ] hit yeah yeah but
his tats I mean did you see his tats
that kind of stuff to me yeah I knew
that though I saw I saw he looked like
it was photoshopped arm and as a gag
yeah yeah it's weird they're very like
spaced and like he's got like a
butterfly California you know yeah he's
cool he's a cool-looking dude though I
think I think a lot of people give him
[ __ ] just because he's who he is but
like
wouldn't leave them in the [ __ ] room
with your federal help no [ __ ] the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah I get it
yeah mmm yeah come on I saw ya what you
and [ __ ] the [ __ ] of Adam Levine that's
a big big I would eat his dirty [ __ ]
nice nice yeah that's moves like Jagger
dude but I do hate when he says I got
moves like Jagger he doesn't dance does
that bother you yeah he's um he's kind
of he's got a great voice he's not that
good at dancing though you know when he
saw next to the ever
oh I got like Travis Scott like doing
his thing and driving me crazy
he was telling me ether it's not a good
point he's thinking I've got moves like
Jagger yeah but he's not the even
dancing yeah that's like the only it's
literally like he's just like you would
be like I'm a [ __ ] you know I'm a car
salesman Lou and you're like no you're
not you don't sell cars on the lot
selling cars and you're like what I'm
literally selling my job I'm not a
singer all right let's take a break
we'll be back with Chris D'Elia we've
got so much more great things to watch
the time is just flying by because we're
having a great time so don't go away
we'll be right back there's never been
an easier time to start listening on
audible listed on any device anytime
anywhere at home at the gym on there on
your commute while you're gaming or just
on the go you also enjoy easy audio book
exchanges rollover credits and an
audiobook library you keep forever even
if you cancel go to audible.com slash h3
podcast or text h3 podcasts to 500 500
browse their unmatched selection of
audio content and listen for a change
there's a better there's no better place
to listen than audible because now
audible members get even more exclusive
audio fitness programs audiobooks
audible originals and more and now with
audible originals you can experience
even more custom content made
exclusively for audible members now if
you want a great recommendation for a
book you can get right now
now many of you may have seen it the
recent movie that came
out by Stephen King who wrote the book I
love that movie was phenomenal
guess what part 2 is coming out soon and
it the book is available for streaming
on audible and this audiobook is
incredible beautifully read written
written read is written that's not the
right word it's beautifully read
narrated and the original book it is
basically a Bible and Part one and two
is in the same book so you can read that
now before the second part comes out on
audible
so go listen to it by Stephen King
before the new movie comes out so you
can enjoy it even more every month
that's an audible member you get one
credit good for any audiobook you choose
to automatically you cannot get anywhere
else
audible members also get access to audio
fitness health workouts to begin your
year on the right foot
get started with a 30-day trial when you
go to audible.com slash
H Street podcast or text h3 podcasts do
500 500 audible the most inspiring minds
the most compelling stories the best
place to listen postage rates have gone
up again thankfully stamps Cobb can ease
the pain with big discounts off the post
office retail rates well stamp calm you
can save 5 cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
that's the kind of savings that really
add up especially for a small business
plus stamps table is completely override
which saves you time and let's face it
folks there's nothing more valuable than
that no more inconvenient trips to the
post office
stamps table automatically calculates
and prints the exact amount of postage
you need for every letter or package you
sent and you'll never overpay or under
pay again stamps or clubs brings you all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your fingertips by imprint
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail use of your
own computer and printer Sam Cobb makes
it easy they send you a free digital
skill what automatically calculates the
exact postage what these people are
sending out scales what do they lost
their minds
chef Sal Cobb will help you decide the
best class of male based on your needs
SAP comm saves you money they give you
the postage discounts you get at the
post office including five cents off
every first-class stamp anything you
could do at the post office you could do
now from your desk for less steps calm
it's easier it's cheaper there's no
lines it's a frickin no-brainer and with
the free skill with a free scale to
automatically pick out the postage
everytime guys this really a no-brainer
if you mail things you've got to get on
over to stamps calm and right now for
our listeners you get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and that digital skill that
everybody is raving about see if your
stuff weighs 700 thousand small
businesses use stamps calm so go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in h3
so stamps comm find the microphone at
the top of the page and enter h3 there
are so many brilliant software's online
and you have no way of finding out who
or where or what it is until kaptara
kaptara is this wonderful aggregate they
put together every incredible software
on their website with human reviews
people interacting and telling you which
ones they like which one they don't like
you just go you type in the category
that you want let's say content
management systems business solutions
money management video editing I mean
they have every software aggregated and
to this for businesses if you are still
doing things the old way it's time to
get into that new year with kaptara comm
cap tears deleting free online resources
to help you find the best software
solutions for your business they've got
over 700,000 reviews for products from
your software users discovering
everything you need to make an informed
decision search more than 700 specific
categories of software everything from
project management to email marketing to
yoga studio management software I mean
that's pretty fricking niche they've got
it all as my point and no matter what
kind of software your business model
needs kaptara makes it easy to discover
the right solution fast so join the
millions of people that already use
kaptara every month to find the right
tools for their business we've used this
pre we've used this to help us we've
been trying to find software to help
manage basically how how to communicate
and organize our thoughts among amongst
our companies and we were able to blow
the name of the software we found them
air table air table it changed we're
just writing emails and all the sudden
we got air table which had these great
reviews we plugged it in and now we have
a system to organizing all of our
thoughts
it was incredible wouldn't have found it
without kaptara so if you are looking
for software to elevate your business to
find the perfect one to make your life
easier go to kaptara comm / h3 it's free
today right now find the tools that make
not 2019 the year for your business so
go to kaptara Cobb / h3 that's kaptara
see Apte are are a.com slash h3
welcome back everybody to our it's it's
a new thing and I don't know who's going
next it's it's one of us so it may just
be me and this is how it's gonna be for
the rest of the grant congratulations
pot now this is congratulate anew studio
we're gonna keep the h3 podcast sign
what we're gonna call it the
congratulations podcast and that's how
it's gonna be and that's fine
and that's what I Erie is he he's back
we joked with you man he came back is
like they're on right now
he just went in and killed bathroom
Conner you know Lincoln's are cheap I
looked up the price after that that's
you were late yeah bye Lincoln real
quick 77,000 for the one he was wow
that's a low that's why I thought I
didn't I would I knew they were not
cheap but that's way more than I thought
they were that's way way more than I
thought it was you know what do you know
why it's cuz that old people buy that
[ __ ] they have money yeah that's why
yeah kinda is young for them right like
let's get somebody [ __ ] sprite and
young right like who it's either between
Matthew McConaughey or Abe Vigoda so now
that we're back from the break there's
now kind of another video I wanted to
show you keep this our good choices of
video thank you very much I appreciate
you saying that so I think you're gonna
really enjoy this next one as well let
me just pop this baby I mean really good
with it to the tiptoes one great and
every way you segwayed into the Matthew
McConaughey well we're on the same page
all thank you appreciate you saying that
they're cueing the stuff yeah this is
fun this is track oh damn it okay yeah I
don't think you really there's other
foot
- did you know that I mean this is this
as far as I'm aware is the whole oh okay
oh I got you it's the whole set yeah so
[Music]
that's my is it cool that's because
that's hard and the Jesus you know first
of all he's pretty good at pop and
locking yeah dinner through the power I
need this hydro close on it can you
explain for the for the audio listeners
just what we're seeing here so what
you're seeing here is a little history
I'm not he's a Hispanic gentleman he
looks a little bit like a gang gangster
gang banger with a shirt that says Jesus
and he's pop-locking like real hardcore
Jesus Christ we love you God and he's
just yeah he's pop walking like crazy
it's really good at it yeah I want to
know if somebody is shooting this or if
you set up a tripod
it's a tripod it's way look there's the
sort of truth where you lay the fight up
all award just and everybody know Jesus
points
and all those who comes with eternal so
what did he say Jesus Christ I love you
dog
at one point I think he I think he's
saying I love you God because that I
prefer dog me too I love you dog Jesus
that guy is that guy that God loves
Jesus Christ oh yeah of course I thought
he was Australian because he's always a
cloister but I don't think they got him
to do a sermon or something like they
brought him onstage and I was doing it
yeah for white people yeah so [ __ ] had
somebody pull that up please it was like
a bunch of white people were like old
wife you were like this is what's this
is what's hot for some you know you're
serious
oh yeah I saw someone pull that up
please just course we love God will love
you I like the Hat I love the idea that
God's up and having like yeah Oh get it
yeah get it yeah yeah yeah he's making
it happen yeah this guy at the pearly
gates he's like he's like breakdancing
yeah or he's just like he gets when you
get that guy's kiss to heaven Jesus is
gonna be like hey man I really didn't
approve that [ __ ]
Wow dude that guy is that guy's probably
I'm gonna go out on a limb he's probably
the most [ __ ] annoying person you can
be around that guy mmm imagine just
sitting at a koala fate with that guy
you'd be like Oh God
you know okay I can't imagine it as much
else to talk about right and even if he
does it's probably the same thing or
like he's like Oh
Rison and you're just like I don't it
doesn't matter that much and he's like
no I got bet they got a bit of family
play you could have a baby you know
that's how he is and you're just like oh
okay and you're like you just say okay
because you know you know he's gonna
stop talking about it but not gonna
switch to Verizon yeah and then later
eyes it I guarantee that's what that
guy's laughs yeah
I didn't get a chance to a man you
wasting valuable food sort of crude sort
of you know are you finding that clip of
him Dan yeah I'm looking for it right
now I don't know where I saw on the
right keyword for sure alright I'm gonna
keep looking moving forward keep this
things flowing I mean I really want to
see that though yeah
so what else we got here today shall we
talk oh of course the but well first of
all I saw that you tweeted out your
biggest show you've ever gone took place
recently yeah in Chicago not only that
but the [ __ ] yeah in a row how many
people did you perform for so that's
3,500 show so I sold that out in it I
don't know what's up with Chicago just I
sold out in a day and then I had to add
another one I couldn't I couldn't it was
supposed to be the next day the next it
was a Super Bowl mmm sounds like I had
to redo it so reschedule it so I put it
for in a few months and then that sold
out in a day so I had a third Wow
yeah it's crazy Chicago we love you dogs
course you love this girl
congratulations
yeah the trip for me even yeah you think
about adding a for show really listen up
well it's not the third one there's
still tickets left so I don't know I
still in a foreign away all you [ __ ]
in Chicago yeah we love you dog we'd
love your door they buy tickets at
Crystal yeah yeah yeah it's it's awesome
man I mean I have this tour has been the
biggest I mean I'm doing so many cities
I didn't even know existed I just
because I'm having fun with it man you
go like as a comedian like I love my job
I love going onstage I was weird to even
call it a job but like to go you know
sometimes like you fall in and out of
love with like touring you know it's a
lot you go to [ __ ] is really hard
yeah and you're at a different city
every night if you're you know and so
sometimes doing two shows sometimes
doing three shows a night which is just
like that's rude I've so I've done that
a few times yeah it's brutal I got to do
that third one as good as the first ah
that's a good question sometimes
it's you're tired but I mean like I'm
doing in Huntington New York I have
three shows in one day coming up and I'm
gonna do one at like 5:00 7:30 and then
like 10 something but I've done it the
other way we're in Atlanta I added a
late show and it was like seven nine
thirty seven nine thirty and then like
11:30 and it was just like I do that one
you're just like boom boom you do this
bit yet I don't even know I do the part
with you and they're like yeah no it's
it's a lot but I like I like I my whole
thing is like I don't like sit down and
write I have ideas that I come up with
during the day and then when I get super
bored of my material which is the more
and more shows that I do I'll just like
throw out this idea that I have on stage
and that yeah most well in the beginning
it is yeah and when I went to cut when I
start talking about a bit I'm just kind
of like feeling it out because I I've
realized for me I'm good in front of
people
and and because I feel the energy and
I'm like and when I'm sitting down
writing I think I know it's funny but I
I need somebody to be you know me and
like to bounce it to like yeah to see
the reaction when I'm saying it you know
so while you're touring you're
experimenting with I mean it's it the
the tour one now to follow the delete
the follow the leader tour is pretty
much my hour set but I do get bored of
it I mean I'm doing you know [ __ ]
City after City after City I'm doing
show after show I mean I don't know how
many times I've performed this act now
yeah I'll start adding to it but it all
will fit within the confines of what I'm
talking about you know I won't just
start being like like if I think like if
we're talking about the linking hammer
so be like oh that's a funny thing to
make fun of like I'm not just gonna
start talking about that it needs to fit
with an adage usually it usually grows
off of the what I'm talking about
well it seems like you've been having an
incredible last year and already this
year it's like you're I'm really
fortunate and I'm really it's just it's
just really [ __ ] cool
people give a [ __ ] back do you know that
mean like in that they want to come out
and it's just it's just you know I sit
and I think about it sometimes and I'm
just really fortunate and I'm really
thankful and I I think it's [ __ ]
awesome and I mean I mean just people
listen to this podcast it's like it's
crazy you guys start you one day you
started doing it do you know what I mean
I still don't believe that real people
are talented have you ever done a live
podcast yeah yeah we did want to his
phone on Cooper fun and we sold out it
was where was it it was oh yeah but it
was like so stressful and so much work I
was like it's a lot of work through that
again technically complicated we brought
all of our equipment so it was so fun
though I was like buzzing yes fun when
you're on the stage doing it federal but
then yeah so we haven't done it since
then I always wonder do you have like a
pre-show ritual do you eat between shows
or do you not you drink you don't drink
I don't drink but I usually eat right
before it's just from added to shows so
I can just because I are so definitely
the middle but like what I would I what
I do before my show is just relax
now now I don't get nervous anymore
because I've done it so much and but
like so I just it's weird it's like you
get to the venue and you just sometimes
I fall asleep beforehand really yeah
it's amazing yeah yeah yeah you wake up
feeling good yeah ands ORS not too close
to the show start you know it's like
wake up girl go on how do you relax I'm
good at it now I I used to buzz off of
the show just like but I'm good at just
kind of I'm good at not thinking about
anything and just chilling you know just
like when I get back in town on you know
a Sunday or Monday whether it is any but
it just being like I used to feel guilty
about like not doing anything
I'll just go um you know I'll get a
coffee I'll [ __ ] chill and not think
about anything and it feels good man mmm
that's hard to do it is it's hard to
learn how to do yeah
you just gotta make yourself to it it's
like like when you guys when you guys
are you good as good about sleeping hand
no no okay so I wake up at like 7:30 and
I'm wide awake and I [ __ ] make myself
stay in bed til I fall asleep again even
if it takes an hour plus and you need
that man it's like you you need that if
you're on the go and if your sleep is
the is is arguably the most important
thing happens and like I make myself do
it I know I have to because I'm gonna be
on the road I'm gonna be I sometimes I
only get you know three hours of sleep a
night so doesn't get no sleep cuz I
gotta get take an early show early
flight to Albany I gotta [ __ ] show it
you know 8:00 p.m. and I'm gonna get in
at like 5:00 with the time difference I
go right to the show I got no sleep I
make myself sleep I'm a male [ __ ]
that's such an important yeah and it's
frustrating but when you wake up after
that second time you fall asleep it's
[ __ ] what we're like
alright I used to feel guilty you know
awake even if ya mean I don't wake up at
like 1:00 you know but if I even if I
were to I wouldn't feel bad about it I I
think it's just from like you get this
source of satisfaction when you complete
what is it called dopamine or whatever
and so yeah from being productive and
and and when do you work a lot you know
and you're working all the time yeah
then when you stop and you're like oh
I'm finally gonna take a day off because
I've been working for 10 days straight
that all the sudden you're not getting
that dopamine in feeling guilty because
you feel so on but like it's [ __ ] up
yeah and you guys love your love what
you do right yeah so and I do too but
it's like what are you doing it for
what are you doing it all for to just
keep doing it I mean yeah but also what
about you guys hang out what about you
know you're gonna have a baby what about
you know whatever it is it's like you
got you got a like I had one of the
heart what am I on best friends wouldn't
he coming just like oh she did she's
better at it now but like six years ago
like I'm like what are you doing all
this for she would work work work work
work and it's just like well but what
about hang out have a life yeah usually
good at it now but like but it's like
you know oh you take it you gotta you
have to let yourself feel okay about
that
yeah you have to yeah III that's
occurred to me a lot recently too that's
I think in the beginning to like when
you're coming up it's so much about the
grind
yeah and so much about just being
focused and working all the time that
when you achieve that success but the
grind yeah going and you need to learn
to be like I have to have a life too
right well not only that is up with your
grinding because you're trying to get
the work and then you get the work and
then you keep getting more work and
you're still in that grinding mentality
you're like oh I got to take this
[ __ ] work now that I'm getting it but
it's late it like I got to grind this
day off yeah yeah you don't have to you
know it's hard to say no though you know
it's hard to like it's hard to say no to
work it's hard to say no to money yes
yeah you know it's are like yeah but
what are you doing it all for is was
what I try to think of and it's like you
know that's good but um I think one man
does have the answer who's that and who
might that be
is what I saw
[Applause]
[Music]
with this place I can beat a college lab
[Applause]
another one no idea what he's doing [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
white people in the audience are just
like okay like they don't let me get a
look at this let's do a spread they're
all way and old by the way that's like
his friend right there
it's just hilarious that these people by
the way if they saw this guy on the
street they'd be like walk to the other
side yeah you know I mean that's sort of
got enough Wow
these old people are so confused they're
on the same team but yeah they're not
real yeah it's like you know yeah sort
of sort of sort of truth brother
it's we're not violent it is but I know
he's short holy war yeah ready to put
all the war we were along but we didn't
really do sure Lincoln yeah I just
noticed the name of this channel where
the stage as member Mike Christian
hip-hop hits justice all wow just as
hard as what but it does say that's a
gang member Mike servant so he is a hex
gang member oh yeah we knew that though
huh because of the teardrop tattoos yeah
that's a little bad I felt like some
people might be angry that I said
well it's a gang member
you're right so we'll suck my [ __ ]
boner of Justice yeah a boner of truth I
mean thank you hit that that is so
fierce with the bop lot it's violent
yeah you know the only the thing I say
is if you're gonna do something like
people who that's my favorite move by
the way there's no way
I don't like a move better though he
breaks the chain like a mo better than I
love any breakout change the ultimate
flex is the best look at him getting it
coming out of the womb look at the worst
technique of all time yo we just play I
don't know but he dropped the whole
[Applause]
Wow man I hate to say it you know I I
don't you know I those [ __ ] are
insane
those [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
any time a group of people get together
and are believing something is pretty
[ __ ] crazy really crazy it's pretty
like I wonder what how can you stretch
the limit of that like there's almost no
exception to them now there's nah a
bunch of people come together believing
in something yeah right crazy yeah yeah
it's to do people are too different you
can't if you all believe in one thing
founding fathers yeah founding fathers
yeah they came together yeah
Constitution mm-hmm crazy they did have
slaves yeah but also how many were there
of those people well there was 13
founding fathers I thought many that's
not a group isn't it saying like if you
have like 100 200 people mm-hmm and
they're all believing in one thing let
me tell you something and you're about
to chime in eventually something I think
there's more than 13 well they sign they
signed right I guess if you just signed
what the declaration you know what Dan I
don't know what I'm talking about
stop yeah thank you no it's thank ya if
you you know I mean I I joke about in my
podcast how I have a cult and I really
want one yeah yeah and and if we're all
together at least it's it's like we'll
yeah crazy but at least like we're all
believing in my [ __ ] you know I mean
well yeah if you're the guy it's not so
bad for you it's great for you it's good
for everybody
apparently that's what yeah that's cold
big-time cold thing is poison everybody
force a lot of people on you poisoned
some people want to get [ __ ] and
poisoned you
love you got the sword of Liu yeah that
sounds good and they pay you
yeah yeah yeah so yeah it's a it's a
[ __ ] they're crazy yeah what else we
got here so oh my goodness
Eminem has finally ignored yeah that was
[ __ ] wild I mean I saw that I was so
happy for you because Chris if you guys
don't know it was it absolutely has this
incredible mmm and impression I can't I
mean this was the second one I guess
they went kind of viral right yeah I did
a first one a few months ago when his
album came out the first one with the
BAP game yeah yeah yeah thanks yeah I
was just in my driveway and I was just
like I did it and I posted I didn't
think of it and it went viral heavy and
then and then like a few rappers hit me
up and like we're like aw it's funny but
I was like rappers don't really like
take rappers take them so seriously you
know I mean even Eminem like as funny as
he is it's like you don't it's like
they're worried about looking stupid
you know so so are you're a fan a minute
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah for
sure yeah and so I did so I did this so
he came out with that 11 minute
freestyle yes and that was like I was
like I should make fun I should do that
but then I was like I don't like to do
[ __ ] again I don't like to do it I feel
like people if something becomes viral
then they'll they want more of it and
it's like it that turns me off but I was
just like cleaning out my garage and I
was like be funny to do it here and I
just I just did it and then so Eminem
tweeted it out he said this is
incredible I like how it keeps it real
though and he said he uses the number
for you I respected that I was like
Marshall Mathers still gotta be story
for second actually guy it was me
incredible and even tags you were sweet
guy that's cool so without further ado I
love how you're out of breath that's why
two minutes you saw he was we need to
deliver funny can I not like what the
is going on my screen damn what the
government what is that on the YouTube
thing or on the screen trike just click
on the YouTube I'm intrigued then
concern it's the yeah you're getting
hacked we're being hacked its anything
just like you what are you doing right
this I didn't realize how very mmm it
was to like probably throw it at the
camera that's a good one so I mean when
you first saw the heat did you find that
out when he tweeted it out how did you
find out my so I got a bunch of text but
I was on my phone and he my buddy texted
me and was like dude hmmm
and I was like oh he's texting me
because it's like two days ago I did
that you know yeah and I was like yeah
bro
and he was like oh my god and I was like
yeah what and they sent me the
screenshot and I was like why I thought
he made it up and I was and I looked at
the Twitter Eminem's Twitter and I was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me and then
my phone just struggling Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing yeah I was [ __ ] crazy
I mean people went back that's like you
know I mean he's like top
all over the news yeah yeah yeah there
were so many articles about it and [ __ ]
it was so funny because it was like you
realize how famous he is right you know
cuz like I I have fans and [ __ ] but it's
like you know nobody was like I mean
people it went viral but and and some
people would write about it but like
once he recognized it everyone was like
Eminem recognizes crystally is
impression I was like oh that's [ __ ]
Fame yeah that guy still sound like
fifty thousand I know he's incredible
man he's ridiculous yeah and I you know
but I don't get is when I before he
recognized it
people were like [ __ ] off you know you
know I'm most people like positive about
it but the people the fans the stands or
whatever we're like you're a [ __ ]
like you don't even sound like him he's
like the people were literally like
though the lyrics aren't even good I'm
like yeah that's what comedy is you know
what I mean and then and then then he
thought it was funny so then a lot of
the guys thought a lot of his fans
thought it was funny and but people
still were like I don't give a [ __ ] if
em and I'm like dude that's
disrespectful my same dude the only
other time I felt that was with Justin
Bieber when I did the Bieber roast and
then I also I made fun of Selena Gomez
on Seth Meyers show once and I got a lot
of hate from from Brazil like but it's
like Brazil or like poor Portuguese
people like you they're like you know
Bibi you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about baby yeah did you ever
speak with Eminem did you guys ever
connect no I just retweeted it and I
figured I figured you knew you that
might have been in like a slide into the
dams moment but did he follow you on
twitter I don't think so no I don't
think he's too big yeah he's like I like
this but I don't follow but here's the
thing though like for him like like make
no mistake he's top five or whatever
they say you know what I mean
like but hip-hop has changed and a lot
of people think that rapping is out of
fashion yeah because he's
trying too hard or whatever the he's
actually good and talented and doing
some [ __ ] he's not mumble rap but but so
so the younger generation thinks that's
corny so what what he should do is
something like what he did there is
retweet that no saying like look I know
what you guys think I do
this is this is you know this is me
taking the piss out of myself saying
like oh I thought this was me obviously
joking and and and saying but this is
what I do and your mother like it's he's
still [ __ ] good at it yeah do you
know what I mean and so like that I was
always like you know it didn't have to
be me but he should he should have like
address that somehow and he did there
but like because like you know [ __ ]
changes comedy changes to hip-hop is
like that comedies like that you know
it's just like you know if you go back
and you listen to like Bill Cosby like
in the early 80s it's like it's not
funny you know anymore like boy yeah
it's like we're doing different [ __ ] now
you know so you guys need a collab me
and Bill cuz I said maccann is fantastic
he wrote I love it
so you said some rappers reached out
anyone yeah wale said it was Tommy Tommy
was really [ __ ] funny and Royce the
five nine who was Eminem's boy one love
I love while I - but Bruce five nine
commented on it I can't remember if DJ
premier said something or not he said
something on something
I signed another one of my post he's my
favorite producer of all time
yeah I mean yeah it's it's a trip it's
cool it's cool yeah it's amazing it's
amazing I love to see that it's just
this this silly little meme has gone all
the way up it went all the way yeah the
man himself yeah yeah and then I saw you
talking about this on the podcast
on your podcast I'm fascinated by our
Kelly oh yeah I love everything our
Kelly related yeah and you mean daddy I
sorry I mean that you have to call him
daddy you might be too old to call him
daddy but daddy can I get a sandwich
daddy no but I saw a clip that that you
open my eyes do that Pulu no this thing
in the oh you can see that until you saw
me talk about it oh yeah oh my God he's
so steel rap about anything the way he
raps is so weird I'm getting a sandwich
yeah just like yeah I'm taking a piss
and I'm wet my [ __ ] and and and like
enough people will be like but that's
really how it is that's like I got so
are Kelly I'm have to wrap this up soon
because my I'm dying I don't know if you
guys could tell but I'm literally dying
it's okay
there's been an hour right yeah we must
in a terrific hour let me say as long I
like coming on here man I wish I could
stay longer than having so much fun with
you but what car come back yeah so are
Kelly's in Ethiopia of all places yes
Nate Ford you know I don't know when
this was or anything like that but I
guess we should watch it before he
probably did a free show just to groom
it is new year so it says Happy New Year
so so listen to our Kelly sing to his
fans
I got it you have your passport did you
get your shots back this is an actual
invitation he's not getting no sex slave
yeah I'll pee on you but but here's the
thing though
like R&B is known to be the sexiest
music you can't make it less sexy then
what he's saying do you have your
passport is just so functional right and
then to be like did you get your shots
like it's just not only functional it's
gross you're like wait for what for
typhoid fever like what I don't want you
sick bringing stuff back to America you
know exactly because first of all if you
migrate to Larry have you been
vaccinated do you have your passport it
seems like I'm seeing in a song but I'm
actually inviting you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah with the context of like what
actually oh yeah that is it's also like
the kind of thing where before you knew
this [ __ ] was going down you'd be like
that's really funny it's funny it's I
get it he's singing about actual things
you have to do to you know it's not just
he's not beating around the bush like
they used to with R&B music you know
what I mean but now and so it's its own
but now it's like but like oh [ __ ] he
really brought people back and he pissed
on him I bet you met girls backstage
yeah dead okay like I said I'll do you
have yeah
and yeah let's go it was like oh so
we're going it's just like yeah and then
they get to the thing they get to the
thing and then they're like we're
leaving and then like oh this she can't
go she doesn't have her passport or her
shots and he's he literally was like did
you heard the song yeah what did I say
did you not understand when I was
singing that's why I sing it that way
that's way right that's why our Kelly
songs are so fantastic because he's not
really singing he's just talking no I
don't think he's like Paul Simon AHA
Paul Simon you should do it he's like I
went to the market and then I am and
Anna he's doing it way Rocher and worse
rape the girl yeah I mean I mean that's
amazing I mean trapped in the closet was
it like 50 minutes long it's about him
being in the closet yeah yeah trapped in
the closet incredible
unreal I mean he came out with a new one
trying to defend himself I heard that
yeah is real awful he's such a legend
any worse way you know what I mean yeah
yeah did you get your shots keep
listening
so with this rehearse before cuz then he
says Rob yeah with Robbie's name first
name basis yeah that's actually that's
how he grooms up he's like Oh Rob we're
close when all sudden yeah call me daddy
yeah that's what have we learned in the
our Kelly documentary on lifetime I said
he made the girls seen it no I don't man
my girl said it was [ __ ] it's
fantastic if you read articles about it
and so on it's all real and like
everyone says it's great oh it's
fantastic I mean it's weird to say
something like that's great you know
it's like the Holocaust was like oh
fantastic this documentary about the
whole [ __ ] phenomenal no but it it keeps
getting away with [ __ ] so it's like well
because he he what he does is he really
tortures these girls that he torments
them and emotion he's almost like
methodical and skilled at torque
tormenting them to the point where they
don't want to leave right so and so it's
not a Lee
go what he's doing but like they go
undercover and the girls are very scared
they're very scared of leaving like a
mom clothes to try to get her daughter
back and she is terrify her de bout this
and eventually she that she comes down
with the mom but like he grooms these
girl like why he's like a cult yes yeah
it's a cult book it really has this
phases like it's like he's got this like
10 step to make you a slave the kids
really perfectly how to do it like it
starts with like I'm gonna be your
mentor and then they talk for a while
and then they're like why don't you come
live with us in our studio and then it's
like why don't you call me daddy
and then I have to call me Dad and let
me take your phone you don't need to
talk to all these outside people that's
true you have to ask permission to do
anything like this again go to the
bathroom and out for me how annoying is
that they have to peek outside and ask
for food to go to the bathroom
the score was like I hadn't eaten for
days and I was pounding on the floor to
get permission to eat food and then each
girl has a room and then there was like
this one room where he were yet sex with
other girls and they were doing a tour
of this house and the girl was started
crying when she saw this room and she's
like I can't even oh I can't even tell
you about the girls were there doesn't
it's a lot and then to make it even
worse some of the girls are really young
like 15 oh well alia and oh she was long
she was starting oh [ __ ] dude what more
do you need to know about the guy is
that alia was like 14 when he started
yeah I remember that and she started
singing that love is just our age is
just a number
oh [ __ ] it's cuz she was [ __ ] r.kelly
someone had her passports and chaozhong
yeah wait is that the one that died yeah
r.i.p
yeah [ __ ] man definitely watch that yeah
well there's a couple of things I don't
get it like did they actually rehearse
it cuz there's backup singers and they
like they know yeah they're just like
passport get your shots I saw this I was
like yeah give you joy he's like Aladdin
on the carpet right now he's literally
like this is working like that yes this
was probably before the internet was big
is like nobody's having like this is a
Disney ride potentially oh oh wow yeah
that's my real Andy Don as you can by
say daddy this is the ultimate now yeah
look at the guy right there just think
of what though
[ __ ] that's hilarious you can see his
face from behind he's so passionate if
you're gonna do something I was gonna
say that earlier on stop because we
start talking with some else if you're
gonna do something like the geez kroy's
like be passionate about a man there's
too much [ __ ] out there do that if you
don't want to be [ __ ] doing what
you're doing be the [ __ ] just cross guys
that's what do it thou papers out
getting a whole fight the holy war and
and there's the enemy over there and get
him gotta keep going I'm having too much
fun I should stop but like I just saw
this yeah this was [ __ ] stupidest
[ __ ] okay so my theory okay so what
we're looking at is the Monterey Bay
Aquarium poster with a meme about a fat
water no I think we've shown it here
before no Dan have we talked about this
before this is the first time I'm seeing
that no I don't usually pay well so what
happened was the Monterey Bay Bay
Aquarium put this posted this they wrote
a B as a thick girl they did this she
chunk by the way is my favorite yeah
especially that they pasted out that
they [ __ ] space it out she
Chah okay now and then they got heat
because they were saying that it was
like ethnic slang its Chong I don't know
about that but I guess oh load she'd
coming in thick girl I guess that's an F
I think they I don't know I don't know
but so and then so now they're
apologizing so but it's all part of the
same thread right but fascinates we said
they never erased the original tweet
yeah and body positivity positivity
seriously though Abby's looking fit for
one seriously though Abby really his
chunk
yeah she's chocolate spaced that out
real a lot and then now here it begins
this is the best come on I can't read it
my throat is [ __ ] hey everyone it has
come to our attention that some of the
references in this tweet are problematic
and insensitive we're posting here in
the threads so that people who have
engaged with this tweet will join us in
our learning moment [ __ ] off if our
tweet alienated you please know that we
are deeply sorry and that we offer our
sincerest apologies if you follow our
food feed we often reference popular
memes to talk about the ocean I mean in
this case the memes used had
connotations we were unaware of until
now in particular seven terms look at
this [ __ ] originated from
african-american vernacular English hey
V and specific reference black woman's
bodies using them in a sea otter meme
with that too it's making it worse
you're making it worse we need to do
better no you don't you're a [ __ ]
aquarium you're an aquarium how about be
better and let the animals go don't
[ __ ] cage up lives Jesus Christ this
is so [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] you Monterey Bay Aquarium I like
you for apologizing our mission is to
inspire conservation of the ocean we're
thankful for your support as we try to
advance that mission on social media
we're also thankful for those pointing
out our blind spots and how we can
improve so here's my theory because they
didn't erase the original tweet yeah
it's the same person having a laugh yeah
I I think that there's a notion that if
you delete the tweet you're trying to
cover up what you actually did and you
need
learn from it I think that's what it is
it's erasing evidence yeah so I think
that what they're doing I think some
people think all you raised it you
[ __ ] you know what I mean no matter
what they do they're [ __ ]
they even did like one of four to eight
boards I like this is a novel yeah I'm
gonna need you to I just like like is
this the point where people are actually
getting offended also sheet chunk yeah
and let's let's let's not forget this
she is charge think I mean she is chunk
dude oh load she comes what I mean I
love the fact that they were like they
also how about if you care so much don't
make your animals obese how about give
them healthy there's a lot of before
this happened other things should have
happened all over the place but Lord is
she karma did you see the PETA thing how
they how they yeah we watch them can we
show it because there's dicks no but
it's okay here's what I want to do
here's what I'm Nydia just tell somebody
to blur it out I'm gonna make one I want
to you watch it and then comment okay so
it'll be like a reaction video yeah so
we're not gonna show it come yeah did I
close this word we're at the end here
anyway so you know we've been to them
link me that Dan you're talking about
the the V the veggie dicks yes okay and
it's so weird to see them tweeting like
what has happened like the museum or an
aquarium everyone's gotta have this sort
of truth man all right so Chris here it
is
Aguila oh [ __ ] no no I can't show this I
can't show this I can't show this really
well take it off I can't buy my mouse
huh
Sheila show it on your laptop that's
gonna be in dick you're gonna love this
yeah I believe to convert people with
this video yeah oh you don't have sound
good time down you can play South Africa
beer okay
this is a PETA commercial yeah
is it working oh yeah it's working on me
Duke food I want to be in this Marshall
but that guys look like such grease but
like what guys I mean I guess hey guys
what guys gonna do like eat a banana
instead of that steak
how many views is this kind of a big job
probably a lot because of the half a
million on the Facebook version I'm sure
there's a ton on the YouTube - hey it's
well done but I really like how they had
the cilantro look at like pubes yeah
that's how the same thing yeah very
compel you know you're not gonna you're
not gonna mean it's not gonna work
people are gonna eat meat I want to eat
meat when I watch that yeah you know
what I literally was like okay I should
eat something like that okay and then I
thought oh but you know we'll be really
good at burger right food makes me just
think I'm the food yeah all right I'm
done thank you for coming in yeah I
warned Chris I said you know what dude
I'm sick so if you don't want none of
this aids you know I give you fair
warning but Chris was a soldier he took
the sword of truth he went on a holy war
I said that enemies over there doesn't
get his cross
let's get him and he came in and I think
I had such a great time yeah I was fun
I'm such a huge fan so I love you guys
man I'll come back whenever I'm Chris
and your latest baby fantastic always on
Netflix comedians of the world he's part
of that series don't want you anyone
else watch Chris first will say is the
man on fire or in it's all there and of
course please go watch him on tour he's
hilarious you're gonna love have such a
great time Chris D'Elia dot-com slash
tour he's added shows because he's just
sell him tickets like crazy because he's
not eminem has recognized this man he's
on a holy war booth the justices out and
god his mom his side so get those
tickets quick at crystally a.com slash
tortfeasor salad out and right after
this podcast it's the weekend go to
Netflix or watching the damn [ __ ]
Chris D'Elia or or Rob is to get in the
papers on Nick and getting you your shot
get your shot and get your passports
there's a case to you are gonna travel
but now yak with our Kelly
Chris thank you for joining I had such a
great time yeah
yeah yeah sure I wish I could go longer
I'm dying we'll do it again thank you
guys for watching I hope you have a
terrific weekend and a great week ahead
and we will see you on Friday at our
usual time regular which is now 1100
that's right is it now 11 about that
about that time that is strange
all right I'm gonna now not talk for the
next few days
thanks for watching I love you
[Music]
you